liberal san francisco mayor london breed
praising the recall
we were in the midst of a global
pandemic kids were struggling and we
weren't spending the type of time and
resources on helping address the
challenges that our children were facing
that's why it was so offensive because
we're talking about renaming a school
that doesn't even have a child in it
so they're renaming the school's judge
instead of really dealing with
some of the problems that you you saw
san francisco is a very troubled city in
many ways yeah the republic because
against the close of the city they're
the hope of the city but here you have
uh you know
first of all this was unexpected this
route for what reason do you believe san
francisco as liberal as it is voted to
throw these three out because ultimately
parents believe that their children have
a fundamental right to an education that
gives them the ability to survive later
in life these people were not interested
in putting kids in school they were only
interested in renaming schools now why
is abraham lincoln whose legacy is
basically defined by the emancipation of
the slaves why is that a bad name why
should that be removed from a school and
you know this is about everything in
life today if you're not on top of
what's going on whether it's law
enforcement or schools they're going to
change things when you don't see it
you've got to be focused on everything
and this woke nonsense i'm glad they're
gone the liberals 70 of them voted for
the three of them to get out thank god
for mayor london breed because she gets
to replace them and she at least is on
the side of the parents she has a great
name london breed love that name yeah i
love it that's not good enough
yes what do you think of standardized
testing
oh
well that's that they were against me
no i don't know geraldo that's not what
this is about it is exactly
these woke
board members were against standardized
tests because they said standardized
tests are racist that's why only asian
americans get into the elite school okay
well i didn't know that but that's not
all that was one of the many reasons
they got the boot and good for those
parents to give them the boot because
they're ridiculous people and everybody
knows it and if the left can't win a
culture war in san francisco good luck
in the midterms in the swing districts
this is the feel-good story of the day
yeah because we now know where they are
the left finally hit their limit i
thought it was going to be when kate
steinle was murdered or when they had
the
sado masochist parade with the
children's float or the monument to
feces but no it was renaming a racist
abe lincoln elementary school when you
couldn't let children learn inside the
abe lincoln elementary school and this
is a good day for america and i think
everybody's really proud of what
happened you have to treat these
politicians like children you have to
say no this might be the first time san
francisco ever said no to anything
that that may be true but do you think
the democrats generally speaking are
losing the culture war with defund the
police and the
and the standards
let's ask them well what do we have
today the d triple c put out a memo that
said holy crap we are about to lose
everything because the potent message
that the republicans have against what
we have been doing because even the
democrats are calling themselves
judgmental and preachy and they know
that they're going to lose it david
axelrod who of course was a senior
adviser for obama he said that parents
should absolutely be involved in the
school as our kids attend politicians
absolutely should not because beware the
coven moms are on the march they are
going to be a very powerful voting block
and the asian american families that
were so upset about the fact that it's
not just standardized testing what they
basically said is
we we're no longer going to have
advancement by merit we're just all
going to do a lottery system so all of
these kids have worked so hard and they
have to go into a lottery system and i
think that even more than the schools
being renamed i think that was one of
the reasons that they fought back my
last point on that is this happened in
virginia as well when glenn young was
running for governor
he would have an applause line that
would seem kind of puzzling to people he
said there will be advanced math offered
in every high school in virginia and the
parents got up and cheered
that's how important this issue is that
they want their children to be
challenged they don't want the other
nonsense that they're getting at school
what about that the nonsense well do you
think that this this limited victory in
san francisco or even yunkan's election
i have you know he's as much a
politician as some of these lefties but
do you think that there is
is it possible that the seeds have been
sown for a culture shift absolutely
let me be very keep going with your
questions
stuyvesant high school in new york city
is 75 asia yes so is that right or
should it be reflecting the ethnic
makeup of the city all right you done
yes because there was like three
questions i could take the third one
okay first i'll take the first one first
let's go back to what you said in the b
block which i thought was important
about racism against asians
that teacher in the middle it wasn't
just about standardized tests it's about
what she said about asians do you
remember where she compared them to
white supremacists or she said that they
they adapt using the same principles of
uh of white supremacists she got in
trouble now she's sue in the city so
there's that element to this where
they felt these hard leftists felt that
they were immune that they could say
anything they want that that the
woke sensibility has everybody on the
run because if you disagree with them
they're going to find a way to call you
racist and they're calling asians
racists and all asians are trying to do
is achieve right you know to do well on
tests so they felt that they had the
intimidation factor now to your point
the tide is changing the tide is turning
the parents the party that becomes the
party of the parents
wins because those are the only people
that will fight to the death with the
woke because when you put the kids in
the and the rest like we could we guys
like me i can handle the woke i don't
have any kids but you get parents with
kids dealing with the woke they will
shred those babies i got all kinds of
woke but uh what about the other
question what do you do about high
schools that are based on merit that
have 75 percent of the student body are
agents i would try to get into that
school absolutely you know
it's like saying what's wrong with merit
if your kid is smart oh that's able to
get into school the same with capitalism
versus socialism but leave some room for
the legacy admissions are all
for the preppies hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else